today on the matt well show the left
detects nazi symbolism at cpac
there really are nazis everywhere with
these people what is what is that what
does that tell us exactly we'll talk
about that today also five headlines
including
a brave congressman standing up against
the mask cultists
public health officials in canada
recommending solitary confinement
for all children exposed to covet and
lebron james
bravely vowing to continue speaking out
against all injustices that happen
anywhere but in china plus
our daily cancellation and much more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
i have to admit i'm a big procrastinator
myself i procrastinate on pretty much
everything but there are some things
that you don't want to procrastinate on
because
when it's too late it's too late one of
those things is life insurance you don't
want to procrastinate with that
you got to get life insurance and you
know spring spring is upon us
and i think it's the perfect time to
start thinking about tidying things up
taking care of things you haven't taken
care of before policy genius can help
with all of that they'll help you
compare top insurers in one place and
save 50
or more while you do it once you find
your best option
the policy genius team will set up your
new policy for you and answer any
questions you have along the way
so here's how you get started pretty
simple first you head to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much coverage you need
compare quotes to find your best price
policy genes makes it easy to compare
policies from as little as 15
a month you might even be eligible to
skip the in-person medical exam
you can't know until you go to
policygenius.com to figure it out
since their license agents work for you
not the insurance companies there's zero
hassle
they're gonna get you the best price
they possibly can and that's why
policy genius has earned a five-star
rating across thousands of reviews on
trustpilot and google
so while you're tidying up around the
house this spring why not get your life
insurance organized to
now's the time to do it you could save
50 or more by comparing quotes
and feel good knowing that that if
something happens your loved ones will
be taken care of so go to
policygenius.com to get started
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
so cpac the annual conservative confab
happened this past
weekend usually in the dc area this time
it was held in florida
several controversies erupted out of the
gathering this year
as can be expected but none more
important or disturbing
than the revelation as exposed by a
great many left-wing media outlets and
journalists online
that the entire cpac stage in the main
event hall
was really a giant secret nazi symbol
according to the conspiracy theorists
who are the good kind of conspiracy
theorists remember not the bad kind
according to them the stage was in
effect a dog whistle a message
to the underground army of white
supremacist nazis in this country it was
a sort of
bat signal you might say if batman was a
nazi and frankly
given that he was rich and white he
probably was a nazi come to think of it
in any event many frantic tweets um like
this one were sent out on saturday this
is from a guy named ben
jackson who writes for a number of media
outlets and he said
this is the cpac stage it's designed
below it is a roon which was used by the
ss
this is the stage from which ted cruz
screeched freedom
now elise hogue who's the president of
narelle a militant
pro-abortion organization chimed in and
said the cpac stage resembles a known
ss nazi insignia generously let's assume
the design was an
error they should immediately release an
apology and change up the stage
not doing so will convey the most
reprehensible intent
okay all right well all they have to do
is literally tear down their stage and
rebuild it in the middle of the event
if they don't do that then they're nazis
so what's it going to be cpac are you
going to
call in a construction crew and rebuild
your stage while president trump is
standing on it to speak
or will you admit your nazis those are
your two choices
checkmate now here's slate with more
information about the nazi stage they
say quote
matt schlapp the head of the american
conservative union who organizes the
conservative political action conference
is pushing back against those who said
that the stage for the event that is
taking place in orlando is eerily
reminiscent to a
nazi symbol quote stage design
conspiracies are outrageous and
slanderous
schlapp tweeted he went on to say that
cpac proudly stands with our jewish
allies
the fact that schlapp felt the need to
comment on the issue illustrates just
how pervasive the comparisons had become
on social media as many pointed out that
the shape of the stage
looked like a nazi symbol specifically
many said the stage looked like a
version of the odol
rune also referred to as the othalla
rune
the symbol dates back centuries but was
also used by some nazi ss divisions
during world war ii the symbol was
emblazoned on uniforms of some
nazi soldiers okay there you go
the stage looked like the othala rune
which was used by some nazi ss divisions
in world war ii
what you didn't you didn't know what the
otholo rune was and had no idea that
this seemingly innocuous shape
was associated with it and what's that
you have not memorized every shape and
insignia that appeared on every uniform
of every nazi division well that's only
because you're a nazi yourself
or wait a second maybe that doesn't make
any sense see personally
i saw the cpac stage and thought nothing
of it because i'm not an expert
on obscure nazi symbolism
a lot of leftists apparently are such
experts or pretend to be
which leaves us with two options either
these sp these people spend a lot of
time
studying nazis and nazi symbolism and
are super into it
which raises all kinds of suspicions if
you ask me
or more likely almost all of them had no
idea that this shape had anything to do
with the nazis
but then they learned about it on
twitter and immediately decided that it
was impossible
that the cpac organizers could have been
as ignorant as they were on the subject
this is a common move on the internet of
course not just people
you know accusing people of being nazis
that's common but also the thing where
you learn about something and then five
seconds later you're mocking everybody
else for not knowing the thing that you
also didn't know prior to five seconds
ago
but the whole controversy does raise two
points
first of all though i know that pointing
out double standards from the left
seems rather fruitless at this point i
do have to make this observation
these people just a few weeks ago were
canceling gina carano for making a nazi
comparison
and now here they are comparing the cpac
stage designers to nazis
because the shape vaguely resembles an
old nordic symbol that some
ss divisions briefly used on their
uniforms 80 years ago
so we're used to the hypocrisy of course
but this is egregious even by left-wing
standards
second it's worth reflecting on the fact
that
the people accusing cpac of
intentionally setting up its stage to
look like a nazi symbol
are not all being disingenuous i mean
certainly a portion of them are
some of them know how ridiculous the
claim is and are saying it anyway
good old-fashioned political slander but
the really disturbing and
also kind of remarkable thing is that
many of these people
truly believe it they truly believe that
the cpac stage was a nazi symbol
because they truly believe that cpac
itself is a nazi gathering
and that conservatives in general are
mostly nazis
i know we're used to this also by now
but but think about it
really think about it if you're a
conservative
a sizable number of your ideological
opponents honest to god
believe that you are an actual nazi
or nazi sympathizer the people putting
this idea into their heads
they know better but the average dupe
doesn't they believe it they believe
that they are in a fight against
literal nazis you know that i'm i'm
highly skeptical that there can ever be
unity in this country
again in general i'm skeptical of that
but if it's gonna happen if there's any
hope of it happening
it would have to start bare minimum with
the left acknowledging that their
political opponents are not
actual nazis i mean we couldn't unify
simply based on that fact alone we can't
say like yay we're all not nazis
let's unite there needs to be more to it
than that
but admitting that your opponents are
not nazis
is certainly a necessary first step
and on the left even that step is too
much
even that is a bridge too far even that
is more ground than they are willing to
concede
and hopefully if nothing else this will
put into perspective our chances of ever
having unity
at all in this country now let's get to
our five headlines
a little more cpac news this was
interesting i thought the cpac straw
poll
attendees at the event um and remember
of course these are self-selected
conservative activists so
not a true cross-section of republicans
generally but uh but even so um
attendees according to the poll they
for 2024 right now they like trump by 55
so 55 said they would want to see trump
as
as the nominee um 21 said
desantis and then gnome was four percent
and then everybody else was
so it's like trump and then a wide
margin desantis
another huge margin and then gnome and
then another pretty big margin and then
everybody else
um now if trump is not an option then
they like desantis with 43
putting him way far ahead of the rest of
the pack
and then noam would come in second and
then and then everybody else
um you know i
probably you take it all with a grain of
salt because we're you know three four
years away from from any of this really
making a difference and a lot can happen
in the next three to four years
uh so trying to predict you know four
years out
trying to trying to predict who's going
to be the nominee
it's kind of like if you go to if you
watch espn right now and uh they're
trying to fill time if you watch the nfl
shows on espn right now they're trying
to fill time
and they're predicting even before the
nfl draft who the super bowl winner is
going to be
in in 2022 um it's it's it's a little
bit absurd but
if we are going to take anything from
this um
i would have to say that this is really
good news for desantis
not surprising news and they all they
are in florida keep that in mind too but
um good news for desantis not great news
for trump
if there's anything surprising about
this
only 55 percent at cpac said they want
to see trump as the nominee now what
that tells me is
um if this were to hold hold up
then obviously trump if he runs for the
nomination he's going to get it
and it's i don't think there's any doubt
about that yeah a lot can happen in
three or four years but i don't see
like there's nothing that could happen
that would stop that if he runs he's
going to get the nomination
but this would seem to indicate that the
excitement level is
considerably dwindled
you know if if there's you know 15
20 30 percent uh and just because 55
are saying they would vote for trump
that doesn't mean that that 45 percent
wouldn't
want to see him but even if it is like
15 20 30
something like that that wouldn't want
to see trump as the nominee that are
that
would be against that um this just goes
to my point that
you know i i i really like i i think
desantis you know we start there there
are
other talents on the right maybe not a
lot of them
there aren't a lot the republican party
doesn't have a lot of political talent
right now
but it does have some desantis
definitely being one of them
i think we should really think about
getting younger
getting some fresh blood in there you
know someone who doesn't have all the
same baggage
i think we should really think about
that uh more from cpac this is from the
daily wire it says
conservatives have the right to gather
and peacefully express their views hyatt
hotel said on friday the hotel chain
began facing blowback from left-wing
activists last week
for allowing this year's cpac to be held
at the hyatt regency in orlando
uh so they were getting a lot of blow
back and and uh you know the left was
demanding that they you know maybe shut
down the event or something like that
because uh it's you're hosting nazis
after all
and this is what hyatt said in a
statement to fox business they said we
take pride in operating a highly
inclusive environment and we believe
that the facilitation of gatherings is a
central element of what we do as a
hospitality company
we believe in the right of individuals
and organizations to peacefully express
their views independent of the degree to
which
the perspectives of those hosting
meetings and events at our hotels align
with ours
our own values support a culture that is
characterized by empathy respect and
diversity of opinions and backgrounds
and we strive to bring this to light
through what we do and how we engage
with those in our care now
so it seemed like and
when i was first planning to talk about
this i thought okay i'm going to give i
can give hyatt hotels some props here
because they stood up to the to the woke
mob
uh kind of giving a little bit of a
blueprint to other companies
because this is this is the thing with
so many corporations
and companies they'll collapse in the
face of the wokemob
for no real reason because nobody's
gonna
it's cpac is already over nobody cares
about it
you know the leftists who are saying
they're gonna boycott and all this stuff
a week from now are they going to be
talking about hyatt anymore
most of the time when the mob's coming
after you especially if you're a major
corporation you've got billions of
dollars
all you got to do is wait them out most
of the time and they're going to move on
so i was gonna give hyatt credit for
this
because they were showing that's all you
have to do ignore them and say listen
we're you know we're a company we hosted
a gathering that's it
a week from now nobody cares but then i
saw this from tmz this is this morning
um hyatt
originally they had responded to the
controversy over the fact that they were
simply
hosting cpac at all but then all this
this ridiculous stuff about the stage
design being a nazi symbol
came up and here's hyatt responding to
that
uh it says we take the concern raised
about the prospect of symbols of hate
being included in the stage design at
cpac 2021
very seriously as all such symbols are
abhorrent and unequivocally counter to
our values as a company
the cpac 2020 event is hosted and
managed by the american conservative
union
that manages all aspects of event
logistics including the stage design and
aesthetics
we discussed directly with aclu
leadership who told us that any
resemblance to a symbol of hate is
unintentional
we will continue to stay in dialogue
with event organizers regarding our deep
concerns
any further questions can be directed to
cpec they're going to stay in dialogue
about whether the stage
was supposed to be a nazi symbol how
much further can the dialogue go
like i don't know you ask the question
hey did you were you intentionally
trying to make this stage look like an
old nordic symbol that also was
associated with nazis
uh no we weren't okay
i don't know where you go with that
dialogue
but it sounds like hyatt because of this
they withstood the mob for like a day
and because of this dumb
nazi symbol controversy now they're
they're gearing up to to uh
fold to the mob and maybe the next
couple days we'll see the official
distancing and condemning and all this
kind of stuff
all right number two i have to play this
because well it's just pretty hilarious
here's our friend our dear friend brian
stelter on cnn
um talking about potatoes and other
subjects that he knows well let's let's
listen
then why was mr potato had mentioned 35
times on fox news and fox business this
week
35 times well the answer is because it's
easy
it's cheap it's really easy to do but
it's so distracting
potato head distracts from the suffering
so many people are going through
the muppets controversy distracts from
dire inequality
this stuff gets hyped up and passed
around mostly on twitter where lots of
reporters myself included spend way too
much time
and the risk is that it warps our
judgment and makes
sidebar stories seem so much more
important than they really are and that
causes even more chatter
and that's how you wind up with janine
pirro walking around cpac asking people
if you've seen hunter biden like she's a
bad meme
come to life
on friday i was about to go get dinner
for my kids when donald trump jr
attacked me in his speech at cpac
something about me looking like a gender
neutral potato head
and then the tweets started rolling in
on my computer people
telling me about donnie junior insulting
me and i thought of some really cutting
responses some really clever ways to
reply
some way to go viral but then i stopped
i didn't post anything it was just
another distraction
he wanted me to respond this was just
more bs
fuel for the culture war and it does not
matter
he does he does look like a
gender-neutral potato doesn't he that's
a good line
it's a general rule here if someone has
a good line against you
don't repeat it uh because it sounds
even funnier when you repeat it
and come to think of it he does look a
lot like a gender neutral i don't i
don't mean it as an insult
no it's it's simply an observation
that's all
it's not necessarily bad like a
gender-neutral potatoes there's there
are worse things you could look like
um but he had but brian stelter
had a great response he had a great
comeback and and and he he
and he he could have he could have said
it but he
he was too big a man for that that's all
you know i'm too big i'm too big a man
i got the greatest i could i could take
you down right now with my wit
but um i'm i'm too mature so i'm not
going to
i could but i won't yeah sure
and of course the point he's making here
is about the potato head and the
the muppet disclaimer and all that this
is all distraction it's a
it's a silly culture war why do you care
about this
this is one of the tried and true
tactics of the left
this is what they're always doing this
is one of their their primary strategies
it's um they make a big deal about
something
and then if we respond to it
you know they they do something make a
big deal about it
and if we object then rather than defend
what they're doing they'll say why do
you care about this
what do you care about this for so
they'll do a certain thing
throw a little a literal parade in the
street
say look everybody look at this amazing
thing we're doing
and if you stand off to the side and
simply say you know i'm not a big
fan of that actually what do you make of
such a big deal about this floor
they're up on the parade float accusing
you of making a big deal about it that's
that's the way it goes with
pretty much everything that that's the
way they fight the culture war
and that's how they often get away with
fighting it while pretending they're not
fighting it at all
all they do is fight the culture war but
then claim that on the right all we do
is fight the culture war
and they're they're too busy and they
don't care about these issues at all
now the potato head thing was i think
everybody pretty much
everyone was simply making fun of it
it's i don't think anyone was taking
that issue very seriously
um the muppet thing though
now this is disney plus this is disney
major corporation billions and billions
of dollars
um they've they are the ones
it wasn't we didn't do this
the disney corporation they're the ones
who decided to make a big deal out of
the muppets
such a big deal that they thought it
needed a disclaimer before you watched
a show about puppets they needed to put
this
lengthy dramatic disclaimer on it
so who's the one making a big deal about
the muppets
is is it is it the the group that's
putting
the disclaimer on it or is it the people
who are simply saying well that's that's
ridiculous that's silly
but this is the this is the strategy and
they get away with it most of the time
they really do number three this is
great stuff from congressman
byron donalds who i admit i'd never
heard of until now but i'm almost ready
to
elect him president based on this alone
maybe he should be in the cpac straw
poll i don't know
but uh i don't know anything else about
him except for this
little uh speech he gave to to the media
earlier today let's listen
good evening byron donald's member of
congress from the great state of florida
congressional district 19.
and for our friends in the media i do
want to apologize i actually left my
mask in my office
why do i bring that up because it's
important that in our capital we start
talking about the things that are real
and not the things that are fake you see
i already had hope in nineteen
the attending position in this very
capital gave me the antibody test
last week i still have i'm not spreading
any
i forgot my mask the reality is if you
have antibodies
you're actually okay the other reality
is is that
the president of the united states the
vice president of the united states the
speaker of the house
have all been inoculated they have the
vaccine
but they still wear their mask anyway
the reason they do this is because
washington
is accustomed to fan dances washington
is accustomed to doing fake things that
don't matter
that's great i mean and that that it
shouldn't take
courage shouldn't take political courage
to say what he said there
and to do what he's doing which is not
wearing the mask uh but it does
it it does take political courage and
this is exactly what we need
we need visible people um people in
positions of leadership
to stop wearing the mask especially if
they already had it
if they had the vaccine you know if
they're in that group especially
don't wear it and not just people in
positions of leadership
but people generally in society now i
personally as i've said all along i
don't think that anyone should be forced
to wear the mask
in general but if you've already had i
mean there are tens of millions of
people in this country who've
already had the virus and then millions
more now who
have the vaccine
why should you wear it if you're in that
category
so i would say if you're in that
category you should just not wear it
and if anyone tells you to wear it have
them explain why
say oh no i got the antibodies why
should i wear it
maybe ask them to explain to you why
exactly should i but let's not let's not
talk about the mask in general terms
okay we're not talking about everybody
me as someone who's who i have the
antibodies why should i wear it tell me
why
give me a good scientific reason why i
should
won't be able to do it this is exactly
what needs to happen
all right number four the toronto sun
has infuriating news
really putting it mildly this is out of
canada it says
peel health has issued guidelines to
parents instructing them to keep any
children who've been sent home because a
classmate has tested positive for kova
19
isolated a separate room from all other
family members for
14 days now
these are not even sick kids kids who
are in a class
with a kid who is sick isolated in
solitary confinement in their homes for
14 days
the severe guidelines which apply even
to small children who are dismissed from
child
care are being criticized by experts as
harmful and not supported by science
this is cruel punishment for a child
this is dr suzanne richardson
says a cruel punishment for a child
especially for younger children four to
ten years old
shutting a child off from their parents
and siblings for up to 14 days in this
manner
could produce significant and
long-lasting emotional and psychological
effects
well yeah the article says the handout
distributed at peel region schools
explains if your child does not have any
symptoms
the child must self-isolate which means
stay in a separate room
eat in a separate room apart from others
use a separate bathroom if possible
the handout also says if the child must
leave their room they should wear a mask
and stay two meters apart from any from
others
any other children in the household not
only uh must be both separated from
their siblings but also stay home for 14
days now
i can't even keep reading this it is
that
infuriating to me if you would actually
do this to your child
put them in solitary confinement isolate
them
this is what they're talking about in a
separate room for
two weeks no physical
contact with anyone in the family
i mean you can't even do this to
prisoners
this would be considered human rights
abuse if you did it to a prisoner
you do it to your child if you would do
that to your child
because you're afraid they're going to
get you sick then you do and i do not
say this lightly
but you do not deserve to have children
you should have your children taken from
you
you should be in you should be
imprisoned yourself you should be the
one in solitary confinement
if you would do that to your kid there
is no excuse for it
i don't care i i don't want to hear the
excuse
yeah i mean you could tell me that you
know you have pre-existing conditions
and all this kind of i'm sympathetic to
that
but there is no excuse for doing that to
your child period
i would literally rather die i would
actually rather die i would certainly
rather
take the extremely minimal risk
even if it wasn't minimal let's say i
was in a high-risk group
and they told me well your kid might be
sick so stick them in a room for two
weeks
you know your four-year-old child put
them in a room for two weeks by
themselves
never go closer if they come out of the
hallway make sure they're in a mess
never come closer than two meters from
them
now you're high risk and if you don't do
that you might get sick and die
my response would be okay i'm gonna get
sick and die then i guess
because that is simply not an option
and the thing is you know you you read
this and you think
man there's no way parents would
actually do this
these are these are insane quote-unquote
public health officials
who don't have probably childless
themselves childless alone and miserable
trying to impose their misery on
everybody else okay
and and it's it's they're saying this
they're they're detached from the issue
themselves
they don't know anything about kids they
don't understand uh but but a parent
parent wouldn't actually do this you
love your child you would never do this
to them
that's what you want to think but then
if this is any judge
of it uh you know if this tells us
anything i'm looking at
you know the the the link to this
article
on twitter and i'm reading some of the
comments hundreds of comments
and many of them are from parents
saying that they have done this or they
ease or they would do it
they're per they're prepared to do it
they are prepared to absolutely
psychologically and emotionally
devastate their children
in ways that they may never recover from
they are prepared to do that
um in order to keep themselves safe
every single one of these parents unfit
and don't deserve to have they don't
love their kids
you do not love your child if you do
that to your kid period
this is not an exaggeration when i say
lifelong damage
i mean think about that you know when
you were a kid you were sent to your
room for a couple hours right
at most i mean usually it's you probably
had to really earn a
you know an hour or more in your room um
two weeks no
absolutely not all right number five a
soccer star i think he's a star
uh named zlatan ibrahim
ibrahimovic i don't know uh anyway he's
a guy who plays soccer and he recently
said that he thinks lebron james
should shut up about politics and stick
to sports that's his opinion i tend to
agree with it
you know i probably not a big soccer guy
but at least i can i can
agree with that and uh lebron was
asked about this a couple days ago and
he had a response that made some waves
for whatever reason
and here's what he said at the end of
the day um
you know i would never shut up about
things that's um
that's wrong i preach about my people
and i preach about
uh you know equality um social injustice
racism um you know systematic uh
uh voting uh voter suppression um
things that go on in our community
because i was a part of my community at
one point and seeing the things that was
going on and i know
you know what's going on still because i
have a group of uh
300 plus kids at my school that's going
through the same thing
and they need a voice um and i'm their
voice
i'm their voice and i use my platform to
continue to shed light on
everything that may be going on not only
in my community but around the uh you
know this country and around the world
so
okay um you know if if
there's no reason uh well no i'm gonna
say no reason but there's no way
uh i will ever just stick to sports
because i understand how
all right very inspiring
uh i think the most telling
thing there possibly first of all if
lebron james is your voice then you're
in trouble you need to get a better
voice
i i i feel for anyone who relies on
lebron james
to be their voice but i think the most
telling thing is he said um
he refers to uh he says my my
i was a part of my community at one
point so something like that i was i was
a you know my community that i was a
part of at one point
like in the past tense where he's
admitting he's like he's not really a
part of this community anymore whatever
community he's pretending to speak for
he's not a part of that he's he's he's
lebron james he's living in his mansion
making decrees and we know he's not a
part of any of these communities that he
allegedly is speaking for
uh because that's why he had no problem
all through the summer
throwing you know throwing the
proverbial gasoline onto the fire and
encouraging the rioting
didn't matter to him he's he's in a
mansion behind a wall
lots of security arm security and
everything else
and so he could sit there from that
comfortable position
and say yeah oh yeah continue continue
uh rioting
makes no difference to him he's not a
part of the community as he just
acknowledged
but of course everything he's saying
there about he speaks out about
injustice and
if there's any injustice that he he sees
he's going to say something about it
uh that you need the big right big
asterisks
and it's it's yeah injustice that
doesn't happen in china
that's the really huge that's that big
that's that's one
huge blind spot
still not going to talk about that
but sure he's going to look for alleged
injustice is here
and most of the injustices that he's
looking that he's that he's calling out
here are not really
injustices at all all right let's go to
read the comments now this is first from
username aaron the antagonist says matt
could you please comment
on google removing the egg from the
salad emoji in order to be more
inclusive to vegans
i think we're living in the stupidest
point in human history
yeah i hadn't heard about that i looked
it up and that did happen now it
happened
back in 2018 apparently so we're about
three years behind the times but
there was a point so if you're a vegan
and you use the salad emoji
maybe maybe you probably would take take
this for granted you didn't you didn't
realize but there was a time
when you know as a vegan you couldn't
use a salad emoji because there was an
egg
in the fake salad and so think about
that luxury that you have now
as a vegan using emojis your ancestors
they didn't have that they didn't have
that luxury
uh roger riggins says everyone is
looking for a rush limbaugh replacement
here it is i can only assume you're
speaking about me because this was a
comment under my
video but uh what i can tell you is that
i i am not
i don't think anyone is a rush limbaugh
replacement
he's the kind of guy you don't really
replace him there's not going to be a
second rush limbaugh
um if there is a rush limbaugh
replacement i'm not that guy
it to to go on the radio he was on the
radio every day for three hours
for what like 30 or 40 years
um to do that every day for decades
for three hours and to be interesting
and entertaining the whole time
that takes i i think people don't fully
appreciate
the level of skill that's required to do
that
in fact i hear from people all the time
who say that um
even you know my i'm only on here for 45
minutes or something
but people will say oh well i love to
talk i could do you know i could do a
radio show i could do
no it's got nothing to do with that just
because yeah you might love to talk
that doesn't mean people are going to
love to listen to you
and what i found generally the people
who do the most talking normally in life
have have the least to say
so it takes a lot of skill i don't have
that skill uh so i'm not going to be the
russian
replacement i don't know who it is i
don't think anybody's going to be the
replacement
um nate shell says i too wept at matt's
touching antidote about anecdote about
the
revelation that potato head was free and
the devastating aftermath that it was
not
wept from laughing so hard guess i'm
also canceled and banned from listening
ever again well of course you are nate
that you would take my
pain you know that story that i shared
about
about me and my daughter and our
reaction to the news
that potato head was gender neutral our
joy inhalation
and then the crippling despair that
followed when we found out that
actually he's not gonna be
gender-neutral anymore as we went on
this emotional roller coaster as hasbro
took us on this emotional roller coaster
throughout the day
that story that i shared was was deeply
personal
um i don't i don't like to get that
personal on this show
but for you to laugh at me and my family
and our pain and our joy
that way is it truly unconscionable so
of course you are banned
um and matthew phoebus says
i love that you're referring to him as a
him
which he is i'm not even for i i can't
remember exactly who you're referring to
that i was referring to but yes i always
use the correct pronouns
um this this is my policy it's really
basic
you know you can have whatever name you
want whatever name you select for
yourself
i will call you i mean probably within
reason if you if if you
you know if you come to come up to me
every day with a new name
then at a certain point i'm gonna have
to draw a line but
um generally speaking within reason
whatever name you want i will respect
that and call you name because the names
are
are social constructs and you know
anyone can take any name
um but a pronoun
is when you use a pronoun you are
conveying
something about the reality of the world
and so when you use the word
he you are conveying
you are saying that the person you're
referring to is a male that's what that
means when you say he
and so i'm only going to use that for
males
because i'm not going to lie to use any
other pronoun would be a lie it would be
a deception it would be a falsehood
you know at the best you're you're
confusing people
at the worst you're lying to them when
in reality i think it's both and so i
think that should be
our policy it's not about you you're not
trying to be impolite you're not trying
to hurt anyone's feelings
you're just not gonna lie and if someone
comes up to you and
asks that you lie tries to force you to
lie
wants to require you to lie well that's
their fault
that's their fault for putting you in a
position where you have to tell them
no and if that hurts their feelings well
they should have asked you to do it
a lot of the events of the last year
have really put into perspective the
need to be
ready for emergencies you know they've
they've made it clear that you never
know what what might happen
and when something happens you want to
be prepared for it and that's what ready
wise is all about ready wise is the
leader in emergency food supplies
they've got emergency meals they've got
freeze dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on-the-go
nutrition we've also got new adventure
meals for hiking camping and other
outdoor activities so as we get into the
warm
weather if you like to go out hiking
camping all that kind of stuff then
you got to try the adventure meals which
are very delicious as well ready wise
makes being prepared simple and
affordable you can order online and have
nutritious meals shipped directly to
your doorstep
ready wise products are proudly made
right here in the usa
and they make it really easy and
affordable to be prepared you can order
online
have nutritious meals shipped directly
to your doorstep when preparing our
meals
all you need is four cups of water water
doesn't even have to be hot
all you gotta do is just pour it in uh
put it in a pouch after about 15 minutes
the meal is ready and it's as simple as
that
some meals can even be prepared directly
in the pouch eliminating the need
for additional supplies ready wise uses
the finest ingredients so you're not
sacrificing
taste uh for the sake of the convenience
and all of that you're getting all that
together
with a 99 satisfaction rate and millions
of products sold readywise has quickly
become the leader in emergency
preparedness
and you can find out why all you got to
do is go to readywise.com this week my
listeners
can get 10 off at readywise.com when
entering walsh at checkout
or by calling 855-475-3089
ready wise is a 30-day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
in taking the initiative
to get you and your family prepared
today that's ready wise
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com promo code walsh to get 10 off
today
and you know there's so many crazy
leftist theories and in some cases
outright lies
um that need to be called out for what
they are and that's exactly
what ben shapiro does in the daily wires
new show debunked
every friday ben exposes popular
fallacies purported by
left-wing activists and politicians in
the first episode which is now available
to daily wire members ben debunks the
myth of the minimum wage so that's
very timely and if you want to know if
you want to if you want to
find out about this find out about the
leftist lies and find out
quickly in 15 minutes or less then this
is the place to go debunked is available
exclusively to daily wire members
so go to dailywire.com subscribe use
code debunk to get 25
off your new membership and stay tuned
for this friday's episode
where ben will break down unions um
another one that you need to watch
that's code debunked
for 25 off at dailywire.com now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we're going to cancel the
golden globes obviously all hollywood
awards shows are automatically canceled
every year without exception just on
principle
it's hard to understand why anybody
would actually sit down for six hours to
watch a bunch of
wealthy drug addicts pat themselves on
the back but some people do 12 or 13
people to be exact according to the
latest
viewership estimates that's why you know
i i watched a few of the clips from the
golden globes um some of the moments
that had people online talking
just to see if i was missing something
maybe it's not so bad as i assume
so here's one i'm i'm told by outlets
like the daily beast that this was a
hilarious and cutting moment from sasha
baron cohen as he accepted an award
for borat 2. i'm not sure what the award
was for exactly maybe he won for
i don't know best movie to be released
in 2020 about a guy named borat
if that was it that he surely was a
deserving winner i can't think of any
other award that he would actually
deserve
but in any case this was the moment that
the media tells me
was especially edgy and brilliant the
daily beast describes it they say
um thank you to the all-white hollywood
forum press sasha
sasha baron cohen said accepting the
golden globe award for best comedy or
musical film sunday night
oh that was the award okay his i guess
were there no other comedies or musical
films to come out in 2020
i didn't watch a lot of movies in 2020 i
have to tell you
was that was that the were there no
other options
anyway dailyvee says his speech only got
more
scathing from there now quoting from
barrett i've got to say this movie could
not have been possible without my
co-star a fresh new talent
who came from nowhere and turned out to
be a comedy genius the borat
subsequent movie film star said i'm
talking about rudy giuliani
i mean who could get more laughs from
one unzipping
incredible our movie was just the
beginning for him
baron cohen continued rudy went on to
star in a string of comedy films hits
like
four seasons landscaping hair dye
another day
in the courtroom drama a very public
fart
yes a very public fart that and by all
appearances that was the comedic
high-water mark
of the event it didn't get any better
than that for example there was
apparently a bit where keenan thompson
pretended to speak french
while maya rudolph pretended to
translate
that was a bit now keep in mind a team
of writers and producers had to approve
that bit they all dozens perhaps and all
had to hear about the bit or read the
script and say sure yeah let's put that
on air
it's sort of amazing when you think
about it like that and the same can be
said about the opening monologue from
tina fey and amy poehler
two women who have through their careers
done an
admirable job of proving christopher
hitchens right
um if you don't know what i'm referring
to just google it i was going to play
some of the monologue but i decided not
to because i respect
i respect you too much to waste your
time like that actually the real reason
is that our show will get blocked on
youtube for copyright infringement if i
play it so
instead i'll let usa today describe
the supposedly hilarious quote no holds
barred monologue
they say polar and tina fey opened up
the 78th annual hunger games golden
globes sunday
with a i guess that was supposed to be a
joke hunger games
timely reference that one uh with a
timely monologue that highlighted the
importance of inclusivity following
reports that the hollywood foreign press
association
has no black voting members poller said
everybody is understandably upset that
the hfpa in their choices at the hfpa
and their choices
yes everybody's upset doesn't isn't
everyone everyone's talking about the
fact
that the hfpa doesn't have any black
members right
uh and then she continues look a lot of
flashy garbage got nominated but that
happens
that's like their thing but a number of
black actors and black lead projects
were overlooked
although faye acknowledged that award
shows are stupid the host declared that
even with stupid things inclusivity is
important
there are no black members of the
hollywood foreign press said faye who
appeared from new york
i realize hfpa maybe you guys didn't get
the memo because your your
your workplace is the back booth of a
french mcdonald's but you've got to
change that
so here's to changing it oh yes it's an
outrage
that some black-led films weren't
nominated
of course i assume there were probably
hundreds of white-led films also not
nominated
i mean you can't nominate every film
that was released in a calendar year can
you
that would sort of defeat the purpose of
an award show
but maybe that's where this is headed
literally every film starring or
directed by a black person
must receive not only a nomination but
some kind of award
you can make up the award if you need to
it'll be like when my fifth grade
teacher
at the end of the year gave out end of
year awards and i'm not making this up i
got the award for best
green t-shirt because i happen to be
wearing a green t-shirt that day
now in fairness to my teacher i was a
thoroughly unimpressive child so she
did her best to find something worth
celebrating and that's what award shows
will have to become
because otherwise you know it's always
going to be an outrage always a
controversy
whenever there's any film starring or
directed by a black person that is not
recognized
uh it's going to be an outrage because
inclusivity is important
i mean i would say that exclusivity is
the whole point of an award show
but i guess i'm the crazy one after all
it's a big problem that there are no
black members of the hollywood foreign
press
everyone's talking about it at least
we're informed that it's a big problem
we're informed this every year though i
still have no idea what the hollywood
forum press is
and even less of an idea why i should
give the slightest damn about its racial
configuration
and it's even less clear to me how any
of this counts as comedy
these are supposed to be comedians doing
an opening comedy bit and this is what
they come up with
now the golden globes don't matter of
course but the utter unfunniness here is
a symptom of a larger problem
and i think it kind of a significant
problem in my view culturally speaking
comedy in films shows late night tv
stand-up comedy it's all on the verge of
extinction
and the reason is that broadly speaking
it's just not possible to be woke
socially conscious politically correct
and funny
and it's not possible to be woke
socially conscious politically correct
and funny
because comedy is supposed to derive
either from
observations and insights about the
about human nature and the human
condition
or from clever mockery of the cultural
and institutional powers that be
now there are other forms of comedy i
suppose like slapstick comedy
it's always gonna be funny when a guy
falls down the steps or whatever but
the best and funniest comedy will fall
into one of the one or both of the
categories just described
it's it's saying something about human
nature and the human condition
and or it's wittily mocking the powers
that be
the problem is that leftists generally
have a poor understanding of the human
condition so they can't make any funny
jokes about it
and even if they do understand it most
of the funny things you can say about
the human condition will be considered
politically incorrect these days
in fact modern leftism is born from a
denial of human nature
and how can you say anything funny about
a thing that you don't understand or
refuse to understand
as for mocking the powers that be sure
you know they'll make fun of the
president whenever there's a republican
in office but
they won't go after the true societal
sacred cows for example
black lives matter enormously rich
powerful influential group
it's absolutely ripe for mockery
but most of the people responsible for
producing comedy these days won't touch
that subject with a 10-foot pole except
to deliver
earnest sermons on blm's behalf and now
that we have a democrat president
the comedy makers won't make comedy
about the cultural or political powers
rendering them even more useless than
they already were
what all this means is that if you want
comedy
you can't turn to professional comedians
for it anymore
you'll have to do all of that all of
your laughing and mockery in the privacy
of your own homes until they make that
illegal too which they might but in the
meantime
the golden globes are certainly
cancelled
and that'll do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show andrew cuomo runs into
the me too buzz saw
trump returns at cpac and the next
superman reboot will be written by a guy
who thinks america
is basically racist give it a listen